hey everyone its Johanna here if you
want to have fun and burn calories then
there's 30 minutes cardio kickboxing
workout is for you this full workout aim
stupid and average of 250 to 300
calories we'll be doing lots of punches
and kicks and these are great moves to
burn fat and turn up on your hips your
thighs your waist and your arms so get
ready to throw me some punches and cakes
let's start this is going to be a really
fun workout so I'm going to set my timer
and let's start throughout the workout I
want you to have your arms up all the
time ok so start with punches that's
slightly and just straight left to right
punches okay so this is also part of
your warmup and I want your punches to
be extended all the way out so no
half-pint just go all the way really
work on your ass your shoulders and your
triceps so if you want a lean and toned
arms I want to see those strong and
quick punches keep going
very nice good don't forget to breathe
and pace your breathing out keep going
last few more good next one come is to
switch between left to right okay so it
is not a high jump it's just literally
with your left legs too right legs okay
I'm Sam and ready let's go switch left
to right as quickly as you can all right
so the small switches is really to work
on accounts and to tone your car sound
right not scale it going no high John's
just really small subtle stitches keep
going left to right okay
if you are a beginner and you might find
this difficult you can just step back
and back okay so let's get keep
switching that's right keep going
very good keep your hands up we want
those humps to be tough all the time
few more get third exercise extensions
up and I want you to give me high from
Kate's and to touch okay the higher your
kicks are the more you will feel on the
back part of the legs let's go extend
and kick good job
so a slight twist it's also working on
your waist keep going give me those high
kicks and touch good job do you feel
your heart rate going up all these have
your workouts
well elevate your heart rate in order to
burn calories keep kicking
very nice let's go
nice do you wanna do you about working
keep going
what one more good next workout
nothing forward I want you to give me
two punches doc
switch and two punches duck and switch
okay let's go is a combination ready go
two punches duck and switch to find just
duck and switch so a slight squat and
switch very nice
keep going I love to boxing it really
elevates a heartbreak and it works on
the entire body especially his if you
want to have slim after thighs and inner
thighs nice one - duck stitch one two
duck switch good job keep going switch
you will be doing a lot more pigs after
this last one dark Street next workout
let's start with our right leg first
so run kid with your right leg and
Patrick with your left leg
okay so simple rotate with your heels
thank you with your heels ready let's go
front kick
good job keep going really click with
your heels and you should feel your hips
and your fun working okay keep going
look straight ahead very nice all right
as high as you can go okay
give me those kicks good kick and pull
me back
keep going
squeeze your bum and fill your body
slightly one more good
so just March it up next workout I want
you to squat slightly and punch the
opposite side okay as you punch press
your body and reach as far as you can
ready that's your squat and punch good
okay
beginners just do very small squat those
of you who wants to turn it just up even
more you can go long okay so start with
small squads eventually go lower and
really make sure you're punching all the
way and twisting the body all right good
go small squats reach and twist nice
these spots and twist keep going last
few more one more good and March it
again
all right nice it's up punches okay
so this move really works on your
triceps ready squat slightly and punch
all the way up that's it so never know
how punches I want to see straight
punches if you want Tony triceps this is
the move for you so remember straight
high punches all the way up and pull
down and feel your triceps keep going
very nice up as high as you can and all
the way down keep going keep punching up
last few more good uh-huh
March it out the next move on my
calendar
it's hiney crap so extend all the way up
and pull your knees in external aware
and whoo unity if you're beginner you
can just do this
gentle move okay if you're more advanced
you can add a little bit of hop in the
workout that's it it's really kind your
abs and feel your abs working together
with your legs and your answer bring
your knees in as closely as you can good
keep going
grab it good
pull it in very nice
I want to see your abs working last few
more rest much adult comes up next
workout that tail takes its slight tips
okay so again we want to work only on
our right side took a deal with ready
side kicks
good bring it back touch okay that's it
so find a rhythm to it and the high you
can go the better is keep going nuts
kick touch and kick this move really
works on your outer thighs you should
feel the cheek of if I'm working and
your heart ally at the same time nice
keep kicking in a far now okay
on the second round you will be working
on our last leg yeah keep kicking good
March it out
next we want to get back into our
punches so let me forward my way back to
punches hook to second hook and twist a
hit okay that's always hip movements
involve go go one two three four good
punch punch
hook hook go if I'm Julie as you can
make the movements smoother
alright one two three four good keep
going
the guiness that was a ticket at your
own pace don't forget twist your hips
okay it's always a total body workout
with kickboxing get whoo-hoo
hook poop 1 2 3 4 very nice strong
punches cook hook one more good
and March it out back to our ABS again
oblique twist so reach up all the way
again
we're moving on the right side wrap and
twist
ok imagine you're pulling something so
twist that's it I want you to see and
twist your body as much as you can
good keep twisting ok really feel a big
swing good keep going you're doing well
alright if you're twisting your hips I
feel your obliques working as a punching
in with your knees and your arms keep
going keep going come on few more last
one get the last work that is the tapas
get into a sumo squat position touch
down on the floor jump out and get into
a push-up and jump back in and step up
okay phony bucks I get that yeah squat
up push up up in
beginners go to your knees down up jump
in good keep going
your last workout you will be getting a
one-minute solid rest after this okay
remember to get into a sumo squat
position
very nice push down push up good keep
going few more five more seconds
last one push up up up good and just
March it out
I'm so then that was the first round
now take the one minute breathe breathe
in and I'll be about and grab yourself
some water
[Music]
good so get ready to have more seconds
okay bring your hands up turn your knees
slightly and I want to see
puh-pow to work out let's go straight
punches good left to right okay very
nice
keep going remember to punch all the way
and bring it back as quickly as you can
okay so do not punch down punch always
ask your eye level keep going
punch very nice all the way go too far
now your arms should be feeling tired by
now keep going straight strong punches
one two one two good
watch it up I'm up second work on is the
street between left - Mike okay so much
it out and get ready for the second
workout ready
show them quick sweet just go good
[Music]
alright Sean a quick switches
it doesn't have to be one but it's
better it is slightly quicker okay I'll
be there
keep going Grima to keep your arms up up
by your cheap all the time keep going oh
very nice
few more much of that third workout
almost i spended out and kick and touch
okay March it out high knees weekend
y'all ready thumbs up let's go kick it
good really sexy legs and feel the back
part of your legs working and reaching
your hands good okay very nice one two
three or good one two three four let's
count with me
four one two three oh come on that's a
fire comes out your arms might be gonna
tie it keep going March it out next one
down jack punch dunk and switch okay I'm
stop
stay strong I want to see those strong
punches let's go punch punch duck fish
good okay so again small sweet as well
duck switch very nuts
okay good
[Music]
doc check yourself and his sweet duck
switch get keep your hands up all the
time
do not drop it good keep going
few more March it out okay faith work
out front and back kick now start with
your left leg front kick and back kick
okay so front week thank you ready let's
go
front and back okay remember to always
keep with your heels keep going through
your hips and your body working okay
doing it cheep-cheep strong case go bend
slightly from your waist to keep further
and higher keep thinking I want to see
those hind front case and backache
strong kicks good
few more rest much it at the next
workout is to squat slightly and punch
the opposite side remember beginners
squat very little alright I'm up I'm up
yeah good remember the tweezer heads and
twist your legs good as you get more
advanced you can go and reach deeper
okay so take it at your own pace and
choose your comfort level and remember
to keep challenging your muscles small
spots on the movements and punch good
please don't mind just go
do you want let's go good
March it out right the next workout we
want to burn our triceps so squats ready
up punches okay I want to see full
punches go boom straight punches keep
going remember to bend your knees and
squat slightly okay keep your knees soft
go punch and drag it down good I am
tripping keep going we're gonna triceps
this moves really helped to slim your
triceps keep going
the or come on push it
punch good thumbs up and March it out
okay now high knees high knee crap okay
remember beginners just take this time
and drag it down alright beginners I
really want you to focus on bringing
your knees in and crunching your abs
okay and slowly add a little bit of hops
in between good
crunch it it movements very nice
keep going drag it it really drink it
all the way back from your waist good
anymore
drag it in rest match it up boom
I have absolutely sweating next workout
sidekicks okay on all ethnic now so same
thing
kick tailslide and posh it up thumbs
down let's go
pink touch good as high as you can do
your other dice and the cheek of your
bomber working keep going pat your knees
slightly as you like
good I want to see those side kicks
yeah all the time
keep going take few more Oh was there
come on strong case okay
I'm feeling the pain you will be believe
the pain - nice one much it off back to
old hunches left leg forward right it
back left punch Right punch hook - isn't
it hook and to the hip okay okay take
care demo clips go punch punch one two
one two three four one two three four
good don't forget the twist your hips
good we always want to be working on his
good one - hook hook one two hook oh
okay whoo Oh connecting your hunt
yourself in and you're hooking you're
punching them person on the side good
keep going whoo let's go
after this one won't work out so you
want workout time guys the next work on
is oblique twist so we've worked on our
right side we want to work on our last
by now so same thing up and twist okay
let's go up and crunch good job
very nice
so really twist a few your Blake's
working extend your body all the way
straight and drag it down good keep
going if you want slim ways and to burn
fat do this workout
[Music]
be more your legs should be giving up on
you now oh oh all right
oh I'm dripping all the way much do not
last we got super squad with push-ups
okay pickiness can answer your knees
let's go let's go
sumo squat out push-up seumas funny
step up good up in up very much
[Music]
Plus dumb
[Music]
as you squat down bring it back down
touch and push up okay keep your bum on
the ground facing the ground all the
time
good okay come on down love or let's go
ten more seconds keep going
find one second
one more good and yeah I am absolutely
dripping and I want you to spend the
time to breathe and to dissin stretching
with me you have done such a good job
I am absolutely tripping so just wipe
the sweat okay and we're going to do
some quick gentle stretches because
you've worked so hard so let's start
with our upper body let's start with our
shoulders bring one hand forward and
just gently place your right hand and
just stretch it out okay you should feel
the stretch on your shoulders get all
right now bring it back and just put it
down to stretch your triceps out keep
your body straight and just gently pull
it down and stretch it out
[Music]
it do spend more time out on your
stretches if you can Mike I got stuck to
my watch it I just stretch it out
very very nice and now I just want you
to stretch your upper body by placing
both hands on your waist and just look
up okay I just stretch upper body out
and now let's move on to our lower body
you've done so well on your legs so just
sit down ignore that and just twist
twisted obliques okay remember to bring
your breathing and slow it down good and
now keep your right leg up and just
stretch forward to stretch your bum out
[Music]
in the same position I want you to bring
your right leg back to stretch your left
hip out we have done lots of hip
movements and this is a good posture to
stretch your left hip out
all right so extend all the way forward
as far as you can reach and keep your
bum down and just feel your left hip
being spread out oh that is really good
and I'll just cry grab your right leg to
stretch your quads out okay as far as
you can reach try to touch your fuse on
your bum for a deeper stretch okay very
nice and now we're going to repeat all
the moves on the other side so that's
like a cross and twist fixing your left
side very very nice you should feel your
obliques the side of your waist being
stretched out all right
and now left leg on top and reach
forward to stretch your bum out
[Music]
here bring your left leg back as this
will stretch your right hip out so reach
forward as far as you can and just drop
your weight down and just breathe out -
we feel your mighty pain stretch out but
can it go as low as you can if you that
stretch very nice and now grab your left
leg heels to your bum and feel your left
hamstring being stretched out good now
just release and get into a child thumbs
and just get into a white chocolate and
just stretch everything out and just
view entire body relax and stretch out
I'm sweating and I hope you are sweating
as well because that's what a good
cardio is supposed to do I love kick
boxing is a great cardio it helps you to
burn calories and it's really fun with
lots of moves and combination so in the
shot 30 minutes I've been an average of
270 calories if you do not want to do
your usual jogging or swimming or
running you can always try these
kickboxing cardio workouts do it two to
three times weekly for best results and
especially if you're concerned about
your hips your thighs your ways your
arms kickboxing is really good because
of all these punches and kicks so all
the best for new fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my You Tube channel and
website do follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys
[Music]
you